el equipo de 14 inspectores del oiea
finalmente llegó a sap orilla
su objetivo inspeccionar los daños
después de que los bombardeos cercanos
hicieran temer una catástrofe a largo
plazo el equipo espera establecer una
misión permanente en la central
por fin estamos avanzando
como saben tenemos una tarea muy
importante que realizar allí para
evaluar la situación real para ayudar a
estabilizar la situación tanto como
podamos
fue un viaje de 500 kilómetros hasta la
planta desde kiev
ferrer bombardea el descanso se trata de
una misión importante y haremos todo lo
posible para que se lleve a cabo de
forma segura desgraciadamente rusia no
ha cesado sus provocaciones en el camino
que la misión está recorriendo para
llegar a la central productos touch la
central de esta polilla fue capturada
por las tropas rusas en marzo pero sigue
siendo operada por personal ucraniano el
cambio de frente de la guerra hace que
ahora se encuentre en una zona de guerra
activa la agencia nuclear ucraniana ha
advertido el riesgo de una fuga que
según los expertos sería de una magnitud
similar a la de la planta de fukushima
en 2011 el lunes en sabori ya los
residentes recibieron pastillas de iodo
para tomar en caso de exposición a la
radiación